previous film that we learn it was the
third poll we've learned general fool
we've learned this is Jennifer we've
learnt scores intercept form and then
most recently we learnt quite ready now
the point Greenville what does it look
like I'll give you a clue it's not with
y minus y1 so y minus a y-coordinate
equals M outside off fantastic so you
can see why it's called point gradient
for there's a point there's a gradient
you're done okay if you've got 20 range
you guys right where's jaqen okay how
are you going
it's like ready for now the nice thing
our point granite is a really easily
transitions into this cool just with a
single step gradient gradient we know a
formula for grades we've got we knew a
formula for granted ages ago before we
even started to read these equations
what is the formula for cradles right
okay now I can say round over one but
there's a whole bunch of X&Y stuff that
salsa calculate rise over time
oh really what we should put it
okay excellent that's am right now all
this other stuff is still hanging around
around me our time like this you're
great this is still aligned it's the
same line in fact it's just as everybody
air in a short-form override the air but
not one for with all the bits and pieces
that have got into it now have a look at
this I can do one little action to make
this a nice symmetrical thing but if if
it won't talk about why it is I'm going
to divide both sides by this guy respect
to go so see how they are wise over here
I'm going to get the rest of the wives
over on this side by dividing everything
through by watching ones one so there's
y2 minus y1 over there what does that
leave you with on the right side the
denominator here hasn't changed you
agree with that
no change this X minus x1 your x right I
guess that type of go off the top now
have a look at that and put a nice big
box around this is called 2.4 why is it
called 2.4 right we can take look in
generation 3 point genius if you have an
x1 y1 that's a single point you can put
a TV here at here if you have an x2 and
y2 that's another point and you put it
here and here
and it will just supply the credit for
you in exactly the same way that point
rated fortune okay and also it's really
nice because we'll cows symmetrical
everything since you've got all the
wires together you got all the X's
together you've got the same sign
everywhere which is better than others
it's quite easy to look at they are that
sort of makes sense now because you've
learnt so many other forms at the moment
okay
a brain bit max me up with all these
forms right now that's okay as you work
with it you'll become quite comfortable
with it I promise
so do you see it there I'm looking at
this one here one in so I want to find
this equation okay now like I said every
form that you've got gives you a new way
to be able to work out what the equation
of this line is but I want to test this
one out okay we'll give this a go all I
need in two points that are on this line
a me two points so I want to call that
what's a point that they can see which
is on the red mine can give me
coordinates anyone okay zero comma five
so that is the wider set that's nice at
least so let's call this one zero comma
5 okay so this is going to be our x1 y1
for our x2 y2 again you can pick any
point you're lying on the line now being
that you chose this one up here which is
the widest death it's a natural next
step to say I have at the x-intercept
now that looks kinda like maybe minus
two in a heart but I'm not a hundred
percent sure maybe it's just like a
little bit off and I can't really tell
so I want you to look at the rest of the
line is there any coordinates that you
definitely know just like this one so
you can't through someone give me an
example as well maybe to cover one I
think that looks negative two comma one
that's going to be our second point
so I'm going to have a go at
substituting everything into this long
form and see what happens let's have a
shot I'm going to begin by writing y -
and then I see the first thing is a y1
have a look which number is that that we
picked pretty sure it's that five year
right that's one one so I'm going to
write minus five
now as soon as I do that this is
something that I've just learned to do
practically because I think it will help
you do this faster see how you've got
minus y 1 minus y 1 again right so since
uh promoter side I'm just going to write
minus 5
again I just want that number is still
in my head so I don't confuse it with
the other numbers what's left of this
Sun have a look look is it not 1 1 hello
yeah just really off the coordinate and
put it into the right box
so now take equals on the right-hand
side I've got the same deal here we go X
minus once the ends one coordinate this
convenient so seeing that right - you're
here I'm going to write mine and 0 here
as well do you see why she has happening
on the top of one so I've got same
number twice the last number the only
number I haven't used yet ears okay I'm
down pretty much there just be touched
to the plate thing okay so I've got Y
minus 5 divided by 1 1 negative 4 I just
got X on the top there and maybe you do
what would you like to do now I think
I'm going to cross multiply right I've
done a review but it's going to be
pretty simple right so I'm gonna
multiply everything everything by minus
2 that gives me that you okay with that
and then I'm going to multiply
everything but over to you by minus 4
thank you what do you think now from
here I can't know what the question is
well I'm going to put this in both of
the normal most public forms I get which
are general form and what LaVista all
right I only have to do one thing to get
into general form what I do just move
everything over
that's a general excellent well it might
be more useful to me to check in online
by seeing if I'd be getting into not
very doable but slope-intercept form
right so I'm going to do this do you see
why subtracting 10 from both sides why
that useful I try to get this into wide
with Emma coffee so it gets me one step
closer just having Y on tone now I'm
going to divide through by negative 2
what I will do to fight that by negative
2 what happens we divide that by
negative now I can do this to confirm
whether I got right does that look like
my preserves fine
the five is that which we told you Tommy
why the bees and the truth is attached
to X is the phrase is it - yeah you go
across one got to go across one girl -
so if you have any two points on the
water like you guys you can put them in
and out any course